[Music]
Seinfeld's as the [ __ ] out trash that's
the thing so I was watching a prize guys
why do they even make the end of the
bread if we don't use it just stop the
bread it's a good point that's a regular
cycle right I'm myself a banger those
whole act all right silence right now
rights right now just right now like
this boom easily 100% easily yeah they
probably got a sign for the locker room
cuz they're like man Jordan b2 geeked
out we needed you know why you is
thirsty them pretzel what do they call
it air air that's a good point
really signpost genius
usako said they're not all gonna hit
why do you warm up not warm down
[Applause]
we call it warm up but then we call it
cooled down but heat rises the more you
talk the more I think we need a last
dance documentary on this side feels
better we need to know man how'd you do
it this whole time
go to a Seinfeld because Jesus will need
to analyze a locker and a room Jordan
imaginal Kramer was busted in the lock
sound that me hysterical
that would be Oh God anyway meanest
comedic genius
alright go go locker room isn't every
room a locker what's the difference know
how I mean you lock it and then you save
chicka chicka Twix I'm pretty sure you
know it come on come on let's be honest
about Seinfeld it's just a fantastic
yeah you gonna have to get no Fresh
Prince of bel-air there was no emotion
in that [ __ ] there was nothing made you
cry nothing made you you know have a
little little tear dressed France did
get emotional that's all I'm saying
but that took like five years to listen
you got a build you can't throw out the
first four seasons of Fresh Prince now
you might have cried before that I cried
a pinky in the brain side Foucault's
make me cry once are you gonna make me
cry no muffin tops
I say [ __ ] we all like the [ __ ] on top
of the mother so why are they just sell
the top of the muffin mmm it's not how
it works it's like your generation
questions Socrates thinking just red
pill in everyday life really is such a
problem with shows named after your own
last name was that Schultz I like that
yeah so why you hate no Seinfeld that's
where you got the idea from because
that's not even his real last name this
is real last name not something you
didn't summon not Jewish he's not even
Jewish all the reason pretends to be
Jewish you don't know that that just
makes me
more Sun does not actually do it sounds
familiar good come on let's go let's get
back to this man oh yeah well you get
back you just do with that all day who
keep asking with scissors scissors
what's the deal with the plurality I
mean it's just one finger scissors
why is it a pair cuz it's just two
things what do you mean to two things
the two pieces of so one each one of
those things is a scissor all day yeah
buddy does a good
oh look that's the best parts of it the
bread bro you had a beggar with bread I
don't know why you can't tag dude I just
kill that boy go home like Bart Simpson
it just right sighs I told you my list
is growing this whole job yes now those
Baroda let's talk about the b-movie